Grief is well boring, right?
I mean we all think we want
to be helpful and sympathetic,
or maybe get mentioned in a big
Facebook post that the grieving do,
as someone who
“helped me through my terrible time”.
But do you really want
to hang out with someone
that you just cannot
cheer up no matter what?
Absolutely no way.
My sister died
of a brain tumour in 2011.
She had a fit
on my dad in his car
and he had to rush her into
a walk-in centre in his arms,
and it was lucky
it was that sister
who got rushed
into the walk-in centre,
because if it had been me, he’d
have had to drag me in by my ankles.
She died on April 24, 2011,
and I was the last
person to get the hospital,
behind secondary members
of my family.
I remember being
really p-ed off
that there were so many people
in the room with us.
It felt like there was no privacy
and why the f was I the last?
She was my sister.
There was only
two years difference
and she and I danced
together for 10 years.
We shared a room together
for 10 years,
and she was the one who
protected me from bullies at school.
They say that the only two things
in life you can be sure of
are death and taxes,
and I find it really funny
that you don't get
taught about both at school.
I learned how to grow
cress out of cotton wool
before learning
how to comfort my parents.
I learned how to put
a condom on a banana,
but I don’t know how to talk
to my brother about my sister.
I’d rather cry on a stranger on a bus
than hear one more person ask
“Are you OK?” with that ever-so
rehearsed face of sympathy
that people think they have to do
because they saw it
in Four Weddings and a Funeral.
My friends of course
were very supportive,
but two or three years of the
same story, the same bad mood,
the same sadness
over and over again -
it really wears people down.
Life moves on and
so should you, if you can.
There are some people
that don't think they can
and that's perfectly OK.
I hear people talking
about how people dance
around the subject of death.
But I think since the
rise of social media,
people aren't doing
that as much nowadays.
These days people love a bit
of death. Grief trolls, I call them.
People who get off on the drama
of it all, you know?
Women are the
worst offenders of this.
I'm sorry girls, but you are.
Attaching themselves to the grieving
and getting all up in our business
so they seem very important
during a really intense time.
I mean people really
have no idea what to do.
Also, I’ll be perfectly honest,
I’m seven years out of it
and I can admit it now,
but I loved the attention.
Don’t get me wrong, I would've had
my sister back in a nano-minute.
I spent my entire childhood with this
gorgeous older popular dancer sister
taking all of the limelight
and now people were noticing me?
Wow, I love it!
The trouble is, however, when I got
the attention I'd always wanted,
It was now tainted with an emptiness
that would never go away.
The universe gave me
all that I'd ever wanted,
which was to be noticed,
but I paid the price for it.
Like someone comes over
and puts a little top hat
of poop on my good mood.
Something will always
rain on my parade.
So I made up a way
to cope with everything.
I had this idea called
'Island Jayde'.
I imagined that my life was
an island, and it was my island.
I am judge, jury, executioner,
president, queen,
prime minister and God.
If other people from other islands
want to come onto it they can,
but there is a list of rules
and if they don’t adhere
to the list of rules
then I won’t let down
the drawbridge.
I'd say that grief has
given me a sort of
Incredible Hulk level
of strength.
The worst thing that could
ever happen to me has happened now.
It means I'm indestructible
even when I am vulnerable.
I call it “special club”.
It’s a really terrible way
that you get into the club,
but once you’re in,
it's like you know.
Like the Freemasons -
but our secret handshake is a hug,
a knowing nod or a wink.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)